this is going to be
the celebrity wedding of 2021. scoot
over blake sheldon yep dog the bounty
hunter and francie frane are married the
tv personality real name dwayne chapman
said i do in colorado on thursday
dwayne and francie got engaged in may of
last year what about you eddie mrs
joplin yes we're so excited about the
wedding e.t spoke with the couple in the
days leading up to their big day at the
altar yeah what special touches a decor
do you have
um well if i tell you that then he's
gonna know a bunch of that oh also you
have some secrets for him yes
i have some surprises for him for sure
so he calls me a rancher all the time
and i am from the country and so i did a
little
shift on how i normally do things and so
um we're trying to have things very
dressy and classy
and um so
you're not gonna rope me flash francie
right you're not gonna rope me no you
know when you jump out of the chute in
the couch
and the girl like goes the girl ropes
and francie jumps off and whips them up
okay i'm not doing that yes i promise
and i love what he's wearing
it's not what you would
uh wait normally see
kevin's been on a plate did you see my
orange pimp suit
he put an orange zoot suit on his
instagram table it looks like he was
wearing that he's not wearing that okay
all right i was getting ready to say
it's called a pimp suit
so i love what he's wearing
and
he looks absolutely dashing in it
do i need a haircut no thank you that
was kevin's next question
dwayne was married to beth chapman until
her death from cancer in june 2019. when
the now newlyweds first met francie was
also in the middle of grieving her
husband bob died of cancer six months
before beth and francie shared how she
and dog plan to pay tribute to their
former partners in the ceremony
will there be something to honor your
exes
we have
we have been doing that all along
and
so and we have done that
um privately
and in in our vows
and so
um we'll be honoring them we honor them
all the time
and so we will continue to do that the
couple also previously told e.t how they
bonded over losing loved ones
we made this
this friendship started
because
we get what the other ones going was
going through is still going through
we're both still grieving we're never
gonna leave bob and beth behind
uh forget about them they'll always be a
part of us but you two really have put
each other back together you're a little
broken and you put each other back
together yeah and we've built this
we have this amazing friendship
also yeah i like her i like him
i like who he is
i love being with him and hanging out
with him we laugh a lot we talk about
everything and on those days where
those memories come up or something
triggers
a prick in your heart
we cry together and we talk about it and
we we've walked through all of this
together and have built this amazing
friendship and found love in the middle
of it in many ways and i i know this
sounds a little weird but there are four
of you in this relationship yeah yes
there are two people who say yeah we're
happy you found well listen i'm gonna
cry again dang it stop because you're
gonna make me cry i uh
we say that all the time yeah you know
bob knows beth you know beth though yeah
you know they sent each other
you know i think they know
right i mean you just you know it's
incredible i would never thought that
and they'll never be another mrs dog but
by god they'll be a final mrs chapman
[Music]